hello YouTube just lovers in offense
this is grunge in here and today I'm
going to show you some of the nice traps
exist in caro-kann fantasy variations
now you can use this line as a surprise
weapon in tournaments right start with
the movie four and black responds with
the c6 so we have a normal character and
defense model and after d4 d5 here comes
the fantasy variation start with f3 now
here there are few good replies for the
black black can play either G 6 e 6 or
the most critical is D cross e 4 and if
your opponent going to play G 6 or a 6 I
strongly recommend you that you go
through the theory section of this
opening and learn about how to handle
those positions but here I'm going to
show you some of the nice traps exist
when black plays D cross E 4 after D
cross E 4 but you certainly play F cross
E 4 and here the most critical line is V
file and it's very very logical because
you can see by playing ePHI black wants
to play Queen to h4 check and not only
that if white allows black then black
can capture this pawn and that means
White has an isolated pawn on the e-file
and that can be a ready-made target for
the black so against this white should
certainly play Knight to f3 stopping any
Queen to h4 check and here there are
three good replies by the black so black
can play either Bishop to g4 Bishop to
e6 or the most critical is he
Crossley four against Bishop to g4 I
recommend you should play Bishop to c4
and create a first nasty trap so for
example here if black foolishly play
moves such as Knight to f6 then here
comes Bishop to f7 check then after King
to f7 we have Knight to e5 check so not
only why to regain the piece but black
has lost the castle right and please do
not forgot why it has a center as well
so that is a one trap exists in Bishop
to g4 line and let's say even though
black does not fall for this trap if
black place moves such as Bishop to h5
or Knight to d7 then very simple is you
place C 3 and white has a very good
center and next movement white can
castle and white can look forward for a
strong middle game so that is about
Bishop to g4 against Bishop to e6 I
recommend you should play c3 not Knight
cross ePHI because that leads to the
Queen to h4 check and again white is
having some trouble in that line so very
solid move is C 3 so protecting your
Center and here in one of my game my
opponent play Knight to d7
I played Bishop to b3 here he played
Bishop to d6 and I Castle on the Kings
side and
the general move or the most nature
looking move over here is Knight to f6
but this leads to one of the disaster
for the black and here white will
continue with the Knight to g4 so now
you can see the knight is attacking the
bishop and if the bishop doesn't move
then the pawn will be double so the most
nation looking move for the Bishop is
Bishop to g4 attacking the Queen but now
comes the wonderful move which is Queen
to b3 so Queen to b3 attacking the two
pawns first is attacking the b2 but the
most critical is queen is attacking the
f7 which leads to the mate
so black cannot defend both of the
threatening and right we'll have a
wonderful game from here onwards so
those are some of the side line traps
exist in Bishop to g4 and Bishop to e6
line but the main idea of the black is
to capture this pawn so across d4 and
giving a white and isolated pawn and
certainly first time when I see this
position I thought Oh black is doing
quite fine like black does not have any
weakness and White has an isolated pawn
but to my surprise I found out that
there are some very nasty traps exist
and that start with this move by white
which is Bishop to c4 now you can see
the Bishop to c4 has a first married it
is looking at this f7 pawn and here
there are plenty of child that black can
go wrong so here I try to cover as many
as line so let's
each bitin so we will start with the
worst one to the very good one so first
disaster move blackened plays this move
which is Bishop to b4 and this was the
case in one of my game
my opponent played Bishop to be full
here I played c3 and he captured the
pawn and he thought that he outsmarted
me
because certainly White has this mode
which is Bishop cross f7 and black here
simply capture my Bishop and at first
sight looks like white get the black
queen
so very simple as queen cross queen but
allowing black to appear the another
queen on the board so black can capture
this pawn with a check and when the King
moves up King to e2 the honor the Queen
appear on the board and if you look at
this position right now black is to
piece up so a rook and a bishop is up
but my opponent does not think beyond
than this in this position there is a
mate in fire you can pause the video and
you can find it by your own I'm showing
you right now so the starting move is
Knight to g5 check now with the Knight
to g5 chat you can see the king cannot
go to the e6 so the only square left for
the King is king to g6 and now you can
give this check which is Queen to d8
check please note if the King goes to
the f6 then very simple is rook to F in
check and if the bishop comes in between
then we can simply grab the bishop and
this is a checkmate so King to f6 is a
disaster zone
as well as king - at six because if you
open and play King - at 6 then well
simple is night to e6 with a discover
check of the bishop and if the opponent
plays g4 then white can simply grab the
pole and this is a checkmate as well so
that is a one nasty trap exist in this
Bishop to b4 check line now here black
and try another check which is Queen to
a5 check and against this very simple is
again you play c3 and you can see if the
black cap to the pole and then very
simple as Knight capturing the pawn and
White has a tremendous development and
not only that right now white is
threatening a Knight to g4 and castling
on the Kings side with it has all the
attack on the f7 so in one of my game my
opponent parry this threat by playing
Bishop to e7 Bishop to e7 has a magnet
of stopping the knight coming to the g5
square but here I simply play E Phi so
now stopping his Knight to coming out
from f6 my opponent first to follow grab
this pawn and ie capture with the night
and here he played Knight to d7 which
had which setting of a cheat thread it
that if I castle on the King side then
black and play Queen to c5 check and
grab my Bishop but to his horror I
played this move which is Bishop cross
f7
and here Robbie I thought he'd think
about 25 to 30 seconds and then he
grabbed my bishop and then I played he
six so trying to get my piece back if
black goes back then I'll regain my
piece with the interest so my opponent
went for the hill so my opponent grab
the pawn Queen to b3 check he blade came
to d6 and after Bishop to f4 he didn't
last for the long but instead of King to
d6
if he had played King to have six then a
very simple line is rook to a phone
which has idea of giving a discovered
check and if night to at six at this
point then very simple is night to d4
check and after King to g6 we have Queen
to c2 check and after King to h5 we have
wonderful move which is g4 now please
note if King captures g4 or Kings go
further then that leads to the mate in
all the lines and the only move left is
Knight cross g4 but then a simple
repetition is rook to F I check and
white will win the black queen so there
is no another good trap existing queen
to a fine line now the third move which
I want to consider is Bishop to c5 so
black wants to protect his phone well
against this very simple is you go for
the castling on the King side and please
note if d3 then the King can go onto the
h1 and
Queen can regain the porn on c2 with a
very good position to boot so in one of
my game
my opponent play Knight to f6 attacking
the pawn and I simply played Knight to
g5 so attacking the f7 and hear my
opponent castle on the Kings side but
the very simple repetition is ePHI
attacking the knight so my opponent
played Knight to d5 blocking the
diagonal but then he has to face this
move which is Queen to h5 and there are
so many tracks over here you can see
these three PCs are attacking the f7 and
not only that right now black is
threatening a capture capture on that
seven with the checkmate and this is a
very wonderful position for the white so
that is about Bishop to c5 there's
another move black can play over here
which is Bishop to e6 and here my two
certainly grabbed that Bishop and after
F cross e 6y should play castling on the
Kings side and there are nasty traps are
looming over here so for example if you
open an carelessly play moves such as
Knight to d7 then he has to face this
move which is Knight to g5 and now you
can see the knight to f7 is looming and
the only way to stop is Knight to f6 but
they're very simple is Nitra c6 and
after Queen to b6 we can play Bishop to
f4 in one of my game
my opponent stopped Knight to g5 by
Bishop to d7 but now I simply played
Knight cross d4 so now I am attacking
the e6 so black has to defend that pawn
somehow then most logical is Queen to d7
but after this white can play this move
which is fin to h5 so please note if
six occurred then very simple is Queen
to e5 white will gain two piece for a
rope so in this game my opponent play
King to d8 and here I played Bishop to
e3 and he played c5 and now I played a
very very good move which is rook to d1
because I exploit the fact that his
queen and a king are in a line so here
after long thinking my operand played
this move which is C cross d4 and after
Rou cross before he played Bishop to e6
so giving back a piece because of course
Y will play e5 but here my opponent goes
for this line which is Knight to f6 and
I played across f6 and after 96 which
has a merit of attacking my rope my rook
can simple go back to the D to further
game goes like this
my opponent plays Knight e5 and I played
F cross g7 rook to g8 and I play Knight
to c3 and after King c7 I double my rook
on the D file the only way to stop me to
capturing that bishop my opponent
decided to play this move which is
Knight to c4 he completely overlooked
this one which is night to be Phi Jack
after King to b8 I simply grab the
bishop and after Knight takes rook we
have a Queen to e5 so that is about
Bishop to e6 and let's look at the last
trap the more natural response and I
give you a guarantee that will be occur
in your game the most logical reply over
here is Bishop to e7 which has a very
good idea of stopping Knight to g5 here
white should castle on the Kings side
please
do not play Knight to e5 because Knight
- if a leads to disaster up to Queen -
if I check and the knight is a goner so
that's why Knight to e5 is not possible
so why should certainly castle over here
on the Kings side and most nature
looking over here is Knight to f6 and I
thought that black is doing very fine
over here
but you won't believe there are good
traps exist in this line so here why
should play this cunning move which is
Knight to g5 attacking the f7 and now
here if black foolishly castle on the
Kings side then why it has a very
wonderful reply starting with Knight
cross f7 and the usual line continues
with the route cross f7 Bishop cross f7
after King cross f7 where it has this
move which is e 5 and after King to g8
across f6 Bishop f6 if you check the
position white is an exchanger
so those are some of the nice traps
exist in this fantasy variation you
should certainly try out this line you
never know one of your opponent may fall
into this wonderful traps I hope you
enjoy a lung my eleventh trap video
please feel free to comment on my video
and I will meet you soon bye